[Música]
Estados Unidos y China intentan mejorar
sus relaciones diplomáticas y al mismo
tiempo el presidente Joe biden llama
dictador a su homólogo por un lado el
secretario de estado de la Casa Blanca
Anthony blinquen fue el primer
funcionario de su Rango en visitar china
en los últimos 5 años en su viaje del 18
al 19 de junio se reunió con el
mandatario del país el propósito era
mantener la línea de comunicación para
gestionar la diplomacia en un intento
por bajar las tensiones que ha habido
entre los dos países por los supuestos
globos espía que sobrevolaron
Norteamérica las diferencias respecto a
Taiwán y el temor occidental de que el
gobierno comunista chino le venda armas
a Rusia en medio de la guerra en Ucrania
aunque blinken fue optimiza con el
resultado de su viaje oficial Un día
después biden se refirió a xijin y lo
comparó con dictadores esto fue lo que
dijo en un evento en California para
recaudar dinero en su campaña
presidencial
el motivo por el que se enfadó cuando
derribe ese globo con dos compartimentos
llenos de material de espionaje fue que
no sabía que estaba allí hablo en serio
Eso es una gran vergüenza para los
dictadores cuando no saben lo que ha
pasado el miércoles el Ministerio de
relaciones exteriores de China respondió
tildando el comentario de biden de una
provocación política
los comentarios de la parte de Estados
Unidos fueron extremadamente ridículos e
irresponsables han violado gravemente
los hechos básicos y el protocolo
diplomático así como la dignidad
política de China
se congelan otra vez las relaciones
entre Estados Unidos y China Cuál es el
trasfondo de las palabras de biden y de
la reacción de Beijing para analizar
este y otros temas hoy en el debate nos
acompaña desde Puebla México Raquel y
Samara phd en Asia y estudios de China y
directora del observatorio de la
política china y en nuestro estudio
estamos con Lorenzo mayoreli profesor
internacionales de la pontificia
universidad javeriana y cuya
investigación se enfoca en las
relaciones entre Asia Oriental y América
Latina gracias a ellos por acompañarnos
y a ustedes los invito a que dejen sus
comentarios y preguntas en las redes
sociales con el hashtag el debate f-24
en Twitter Facebook e Instagram estamos
como arroba franas24 raya al piso es y a
mí me encuentran en Twitter como arroba
maríacle además quiero saludar a quienes
escuchan este debate en podcast a través
de las plataformas de Apple podcast
Spotify deezer y TuneIn
quiero comenzar con Raquel Gracias por
acompañarnos aquí en el debate Cómo
entender que primero Anthony blinken
haga este viaje para abrir los las
líneas de comunicación entre Washington
y Beijing y un día después Joe biden ya
me dictador a chilling
Muchas gracias María Clara bueno en este
caso es muy era muy necesario este Esta
visita por parte del secretario de
estado hacia Beijing debido a todo lo
que había dado respecto a al tema de los
Globos como bien se mencionaba y cómo es
posible es posible de alguna manera en
la manera en la forma en cómo son dos
tipos de líneas políticas distintas por
un lado es la parte diplomática en la
cual de alguna manera este pues es el
propio blinken quien está tratando de
subsanar y de mantener lo más sanas
posibles estas relaciones entre dos
potencias clave en la política
internacional mientras que por otro lado
estamos viendo a un no sé si a un
presidente o a un actor político
estadounidense en plena campaña
electoral hacia el próximo año no en el
cual de alguna manera este pues bueno
este discurso que de alguna forma es
sumamente desafortunado no solamente en
los comentarios sino en el timing en el
cual se realiza de alguna forma este
pues bueno prácticamente va a deshacer
todo el trabajo diplomático que se había
logrado con Esta visita por parte de
blinquen a a Beijing y obviamente el
tema de la reacción por parte de China
es esta cuestión en el cual Pues bueno
un actor como lo es el presidente biden
sin importar En qué papel o en qué rol
esté jugando en la en su vida política
siempre va a tener un impacto dentro de
la manera en Cómo se vincula en la
política internacional y sobre todo esta
cuestión de política exterior por lo que
de alguna manera pues bueno deja
totalmente en un este momento de nuevo
este de frialdad hay que esperar en
próximos días a ver las reacciones por
parte de de las dos partes con respecto
a Hacia dónde irá tomando camino o un
mayor enfriamiento de esta relación
entre Estados Unidos y China
Lorenzo Gracias por estar aquí con
nosotros o escuchábamos a Raquel que nos
decía que esto hace parte de dos líneas
políticas blinken subsanando la
diplomacia con China y por otro lado un
biden precandidato demócrata pensando
quizás más en las elecciones de su país
que en las relaciones bilaterales con
china Cuál es su comentario sobre estos
desencuentros
Así es un error
demasiado sinceros en la política no es
la mejor estrategia pero también de otro
lado hay que recordar que uno de los
puntos firmes de Estados Unidos en su
relación con China y eso ya desde el
gobierno Obama es que Estados Unidos no
pondrá de un lado sus valores en su
relación con china por lo tanto Estados
Unidos siempre va a insistir sobre Esa
diferencia entre Estados Unidos como
potencia democrática y
China como su rival estratégico
dictatorial autocrático comunista y todo
lo posible lado negativo que se le
pueden encontrar a régimen de shippin al
contrario china quiere ser tratado de
para par china quiere que Estados Unidos
reconozca y tenga en consideración los
intereses
nada tengan consideración que china
quiere una una esfera de influencia por
eso el tema de Taiwán están Están
delicado mientras Estados Unidos tiene
la línea política de ser ellos la única
superpotencia de sostener el orden
global liberal y por lo tanto no están
dispuesto a reconocer que que son
potencias de parar y usted habla de
Taiwán que sin duda alguna lo
debatiremos más adelante Pero primero
quiero preguntarle Raquel afirma que las
palabras de biden deshacen el trabajo
diplomático que blinquen hizo durante
dos días en China usted coincide con
ella sí de un lado Sí yo no creo que ese
comentario fuera planificado aunque no
puede estar en la cabeza de yo creo que
ese es el escapó decir así y eso sin
duda complica complica la relación es
pero esa hace parte también de otra de
las estrategias de Estados Unidos que la
llamada ambigüedad estratégica Entonces
si de un lado
van a apaciguarse buscan normalizar las
relaciones con china del otro lado
también hacen provocaciones como
recordamos el año pasado la visita de
Nancy pelosi hasta Iván y es obviamente
una contradicción parece una
contradicción pero esta hace parte de la
estrategia de Estados Unidos hacia China
y creo que los chinos también también lo
saben Pero ellos obviamente deben
reclamar su su dignidad como como
grandes potencias deben de reclamar que
se respete el protocolo y obviamente no
pueden aceptar un insulto por parte del
presidente de Estados Unidos
usted de la ambigüedad como una
estrategia en materia de relaciones
internacionales de Estados Unidos Raquel
pero le quiero preguntar esto funciona
con China o puede congelar de nuevo las
relaciones entre los dos países
bueno la lectura que yo hago al respecto
es que más allá de esta estrategia de
ambigüedad también un fenómeno que se
viene presentando desde Donald Trump
hacia estos este días es esta diplomacia
donde de alguna forma pareciera ser que
el interior de de Estados Unidos no hay
una directriz y aparecen nuevos actores
No ya se mencionaba esta cuestión de
cómo se realiza para diplomacia
estadounidense con Taiwán como de alguna
manera este blinquen puede dar una
declaración por otro lado vaiden dice
otra cuestión situaciones que digamos
que la visión como más tradicional en
Cómo ejecuta su política exterior china
pues obviamente digamos que son dos
perspectivas distintas en las cuales
pues la comunicación no se vuelve
asertiva porque Porque mientras un de un
lado existe esta ambigüedad existe
digamos estos múltiples canales de
comunicación con información distinta
del lado de China hay una directriz no O
sea desde lo que puede mencionar el
presidente hasta lo que puede mencionar
la vocera Mao o en este caso el
canciller siempre va a haber una línea
este digamos muy marcada por parte de
china en función al igual que como lo
mencionaba mi colega Respecto a los
valores estadounidenses también los
chinos buscan de alguna manera poner
sobre la mesa este tipo de valores no
como cuál Como este este margen de cinco
negociaciones que se hicieron con
blinquen el domingo pasado con el
presidente chimpín donde se buscaba de
alguna manera mantener esta postura en
la cual Estados Unidos digamos ninguna
de estas dos potencias tratando de
desplazar a la otra en esta parte en
cursiva de la reunión también Buscar
esta dinámica en la cual de alguna
manera limitar el actuar de Estados
Unidos con respecto a la temática de
Taiwán y por otro lado también limitar a
China con otro tipo de aspiraciones
hegemónicas al menos en el discurso No
ya la praxis digamos es otra resultado
de ello es esta declaración de biden Y
probablemente muchísimas otras acciones
chinas que también en la praxis Eh pues
pueden ser contradictorias Al momento de
que se genera este diálogo diplomático
y también Más allá de la palabra
dictador Joe biden hizo un
pronunciamiento que en el que daba
información que hasta ahora se conocía
solo en la inteligencia estadounidense y
lo hizo público en este evento en
California yo le quería Le quiero
preguntar Raquel Cuáles pueden ser las
consecuencias de que biden haya
explicado Queen supuestamente no sabía
absolutamente nada de los Globos que
sobrevolaron en febrero Canadá y Estados
Unidos y que lo cogió básicamente por
sorpresa
En mi opinión creo que el escenario por
parte de la reacción china Más allá de
que ya se dieron estas declaraciones
dentro de el Ministerio de relaciones
exteriores eh los puntos clave en esta
vinculación que hubo con blinken era el
tema de las sanciones que hayas empresas
estadounidenses dentro de china en lo
personal creo que va a ser ahí donde va
a entrar este tipo de acciones o
contracciones mejor dicho con respecto a
las declaraciones de baile no bien a
nivel digamos de diálogo político de
alguna forma lo que va a buscar china es
seguir manteniendo esta relación Lo más
sana posible ya lo decía el presidente
que lo que menos quiere el mundo es que
dos potencias se confronten y hacía
alusión un tanto a no generar una
especie de nueva guerra fría y por otro
lado pues bueno creo que el punto donde
china sigue teniendo un mayor campo de
acción y más en todo cómo ha devenido la
economía global sigue siendo esta forma
en la cual china sigue siendo un
protagonista clave en el comercio en la
parte de inversiones alrededor del mundo
y que de alguna forma es ahí donde pues
Estados Unidos sigue siendo dependiente
de los productos chinos de parte de esta
dinámica de suministro de inversiones
etcétera etcétera por lo tanto creo que
es ahí donde vendrá Digamos como que la
estrategia china por tratar de apaciguar
de nuevo la dinámica con Estados Unidos
y a pesar de la alta dependencia de
Estados Unidos por parte del comercio y
el mercado chino Joe biden también
afirmó que no debía tener se lee tanto a
China y que había que bajar un poco la
importancia que se le daba esto lo dijo
con otras palabras Lorenzo yo le quiero
preguntar esto lo dice biden el
presidente de Estados Unidos con un
argumento basado en la realidad o lo
dice biden el candidato
bueno vayan
que quiere que diga claramente vayan va
a decir que Estados Unidos va a seguir
siendo la única superpotencia del
planeta y que de hecho uno de los puntos
firme de la estrategia de la política
exterior de Estados Unidos no permitir
que ninguna potencia rival pueda surgir
y China tiene al contrario la ambición
de surgir pero quería quería agregar que
china también sabe hacer este juego de
la ambigüedad no es solo Estados Unidos
si de un lado dice que se deben acercar
que deben Buscar un diálogo de otro lado
china también sabe hacer el juego
de los Globos espías estaban o estaba
leyendo en político que van a hacer unas
ejercitaciones conjuntas en una base
militar en Cuba entonces
china también se está acercando con su
estrategia militar a la frontera de
Estados Unidos así como sonido está
haciendo sus ejercicios militares están
mandando sus buques cerca de China
Entonces está jugando este este juego en
muchísimos niveles desde el nivel de la
propaganda que es el que Obviamente el
día a día tenemos la declaraciones de
los líderes el discurso militar y el
discurso del derecho internacional Sí
este partido entre las dos
superpotencias está dando en muchos
niveles y ahí baiden a veces Quiero
decir que mete un poquito la pata así
como como hoy no había ninguna necesidad
de declarar que es un dictador y que
quiere que contesta los chinos van a
reaccionar de manera firme diciendo que
son absorbidas usted habla del aspecto
militar Y ese precisamente fue uno de
los temas vitales de la visita de
Anthony blinken a China sin embargo
después de que se reunió con el
presidente
afirmó que no había logrado mejorar la
coordinación entre los ejércitos
estadounidenses y chinos como lo querían
Cuál es la importancia de que se logre
esta coordinación sobre todo para el mar
de china meridional porque recordemos
que hasta hace un par de meses hubo dos
riesgos que el ejército estadounidense
denunció en el que supuestamente buques
chinos estuvieron demasiado cerca de
buques estadounidenses en esta área
cerca del estrecho de Taiwán y que casi
chocan
Sí eso es un tema muy delicado y el mar
de chino del sur así como el mar de
chino del Norte son unos de los fagos
donde se podría dar una confrontación
directa entre las dos superpotencias
Entonces nosotros que estamos pendientes
de la política internacional
allá Es un escenario muy interesante ver
cómo se mueve la superpotencias
según Estados Unidos esos mares son
mares internacionales sí O mejor dicho
según el derecho internacional esos esos
mares son mares internacionales chinas
reclama que el estrecho de Taiwán es un
mar interno de China del momento que
ellos son el legítimo gobierno según el
partido comunista Chino Sobre Taiwán
también por lo tanto De quién es el Mar
el mar es de quien lo patrulla quien
patrulla el mar Ese es suyo por lo tanto
tanto china como Estados Unidos y
también las potencias menores porque
filipinas Japón también deben patrullar
personas de mar que reclaman como
propios Y eso es una gran fuente de
tensiones pero de otro lado está la otra
dimensión que es tanto Estados Unidos
como china están en el consejo de
seguridad de las Naciones Unidas por lo
tanto es necesario una coordinación de
esos dos de esos cinco países que tienen
el asiento permanente en el consejo de
seguridad para resolver los asuntos
globales Entonces no pueden No hablarse
esas dos superpotencias en temas en todo
el planeta desde Haití donde los chinos
y los estadounidenses tienen su fuerza
de mantenimiento de la paz a toda la
parte del planeta por lo tanto es
fundamental que esos países tengan un
diálogo cercano usted habla más que todo
de la necesidad de esta coordinación
militar en el plano internacional Pero
Raquel Por qué se necesita que los
ejércitos de Estados Unidos y China
estén coordinados sobre todo lo que
respecta al mar de China meridional
Bueno en ese sentido de alguna manera
con esta situación en la cual
mencionaban el hecho de que existe este
tipo de de diálogos A lo mejor en otras
temáticas como el temas de misiones de
mantenimiento de paz por ejemplo
resultado también de Esta visita el tema
Corea del Norte donde también fue uno de
los temas que se dialogaron dentro de
esta reunión con el presidente y
blinquen no obstante el el punto lo lo
voy a explicar desde la lógica china en
esta visión un tanto es inocéntrica de
alguna forma es el hecho de que este
territorio como bien lo mencionaban más
allá de lo que dice la unclos de alguna
forma es reclamado como parte de del mar
territorial este chino y en este caso
pues los focos de atención Más allá de
las otras disputas que están en el mar
de este meridional de china en este caso
el estrecho de Taiwán se vuelve un punto
sumamente importante Por qué Porque
prácticamente Pues bueno son estas dos
visiones este distintas en las cuales
por un lado a través de un reclamo
histórico a través de una cuestión de
desconocimiento hacia un gobierno que es
el taiwanés Beijing reclama este
territorio de alguna forma se perfila
entre estos proyectos a largo plazo que
tiene el partido comunista chino a
integrar totalmente a China no más allá
de esa situación un punto interesante
también es cómo se va a reconfigurando
toda esta dinámica en términos de
seguridad internacional donde hoy por
hoy también parte de este
posicionamiento este que ha tenido
Estados Unidos principalmente reavivado
por biden el tema del corredor
indopacífico donde de alguna forma Pues
bueno se generan este tipo de alianzas
estratégicas como una especie de medida
de contención hacia la expansión china
dentro de lo que es Asia Pacífico y
otras regiones de del mundo a través de
estrategias geoeconómicas de alguna
forma Pues bueno esta dinámica de cómo
se posicionan los dos principales
ejércitos del mundo en cuanto cuestiones
de este de de capacidad militar pero
también de habilitación tecnológica pero
también de aspectos de disponibilidad de
efectivos de alguna forma lleva cada vez
a que los puntos de encuentro de diálogo
entre Estados Unidos y China se han
reducido por aquellos puntos donde No
necesariamente converge este diálogo no
sin embargo creo que hasta hoy para la
política internacional para cuestiones
incluso de gobernanza global el hecho de
que dialoguen más que se confronten
sigue siendo el escenario que nos
conviene a todas y a todos alrededor del
mundo y según esta conveniencia Usted
cree que puede estar a corto plazo un
eventual enfrentamiento por Taiwán y
aquí simplemente Añadir algo para
nuestra audiencia Y es que la postura de
Beijing es que Taiwán es un territorio
que pertenece a China y que se deberá
unificar en algún momento al país
continental mientras que Taiwán dice que
el estatus quo se debe mantener ese
estatus quo es que Taiwán
no tiene ni unificación ni Independencia
pero tampoco uso de la fuerza es decir
china no podría utilizar la fuerza para
unir y unificar a Taiwán Y esa es un
poco la la atención que existe porque
Estados Unidos Aunque defiende el statu
quo dice que no va a permitir que de
manera unilateral ninguna de las dos
partes cambie ese statu quo ante este
panorama Usted cree que puede haber un
eventual enfrentamiento en poco tiempo
Bueno creo que sería muy arriesgado dar
una fecha o una aproximación de meses en
lo personal Considero que lo más sano Es
que este tema se siga postergando hasta
más hasta donde pueda en qué sentido en
la cuestión de que de alguna manera creo
que el conflicto que se pudiera desatar
en el estrecho de Taiwán sería un
conflicto no visto en otros momentos de
la de la historia no entonces debido a a
toda esta capacidad militar que ya
hablábamos Hace algunos momentos sobre
cómo se reconfiguran estas alianzas
Entonces en ese sentido creo que lo más
este el escenario óptimo es de que este
tema de Taiwán Más allá de que tanto
Estados Unidos como lo es es china
muchas veces pareciera ser que es un
tema que manipulan cada uno de estos
estados hacia sus intereses nacionales y
también hacia su posicionamiento
internacional se mantenga no en esta
dinámica en la que de alguna forma no se
dé ningún otro tipo de acción que ya
está identificada no como una una
ofensiva con respecto a Taiwán o que en
este caso Estados Unidos reaccione de
otra manera en la que se ha interpretada
desde desde China o desde Medellín mejor
dicho como una amenaza a al estatus quo
este chino no entonces creo que ese
sería la situación y sería muy
aventurado decir cuándo este sucedería
algo así para no correr en este en este
bola de futuro y la lectura de qué
podría pasar Lorenzo yo le quiero
cambiar la pregunta a usted sobre Taiwán
y es Cómo entender esta posición de
Estados Unidos y si también hace parte
de esta ambigüedad de la que usted nos
estaba hablando que por un lado diga
respeto el statu quo de Taiwán pero no
quiero intervención unilateral de nadie
por supuesto
hace parte de esa estrategia de
ambigüedad estratégica
De hecho cuando Estados Unidos reconoce
a China diplomáticamente en 1979 declara
que se va a ajustar a la política de una
sola china es decir existe solamente una
china y que reconoce que esta iguana se
parte del territorio de China pero de
otro lado en el en el mismo tiempo en
1969 hace el famoso Taiwán donde declara
que Estados Unidos va a proteger la
bienestar económico y social del pueblo
taiwanés
le preguntaron cuando fue elegido como
presidente de Estados Unidos que va a
ser Estados Unidos en el caso en que
china invada Taiwán
respondió le preguntaron va
es un compromiso que Estados Unidos
tiene con Taiwán Por qué Porque Estados
Unidos le pega a la política de una sola
china las famosas seis garantías que le
da al gobierno de Taiwán que es por
ejemplo no dejar de vender armas a
Estados Unidos y que no va a modificar
todas las relaciones que tenía antes de
1979 con Taiwán y toda una serie de
garantías que Estados Unidos le promete
a Taiwán últimamente china a mano que
está teniendo un rol y un estatus
internacional más fuerte Se está
quejando de este Fato le estás diciendo
la política de una sola china debe
cumplirse de manera estricta así así
como lo hacen los demás países quiero
darle la bienvenida a Jorge Jaén quien
está en Santiago de Chile él es profesor
de relaciones internacionales y
embajador chileno en China Jorge Gracias
por acompañarnos estamos discutiendo un
poco la situación de Taiwán y le quiero
preguntar veníamos de explicar esta
ambigüedad estratégica de Estados Unidos
respecto a las diferentes posturas que
toma y también la promesa de biden de
defender a Taiwán en caso tal de que los
chinos decidan invadir este territorio
como entender entonces que por un lado
Joe biden se comprometa militarmente a
defender a Taiwán en en esa hipótesis
pero por el otro lado Estados Unidos no
reconozca a Taiwán como un país
independiente
sí Y acá yo creo que es importante
subrayar la importancia de lo que
Estados Unidos ha denominado su política
de ambigüedad estratégica hacia Taiwán y
el problema que hay y que enfrenta la
política exterior de Estados Unidos
reshota es el siguiente Por una parte
Estados Unidos quiere garantizar la
autodeterminación y que el pueblo Taiwán
pueda continuar en su propio camino en
su propio destino por otra no quiere
incentivar un movimiento
independentista que podría realmente
llevar a una situación prevélica o
derechamente bélica por eso que el
garantizar en un cien por ciento o eh
con garantías absolutas que Estados
Unidos siempre va a defender en
circunstancias a Taiwán de todo ataque
por parte de China es algo que Estados
Unidos Hasta ahora ha querido evitar
salvo por estas declaraciones del
presidente biden que han causado
bastante conmoción y que han sido
explicadas distintas formas por la misma
casa blanca Entonces yo creo que acá
tenemos un problema Estados Unidos tiene
un problema serio de cómo equilibrar
esos dos requerimientos de Por una parte
darla tal cual el apoyo que requiere
Pero por otra no incentivar un
movimiento independentista que podría
llevar una situación muy compleja y esta
disyuntiva no solo la vemos en Taiwán
sino también en otro punto que es vital
para Estados Unidos y es la guerra en
Ucrania de hecho luego de su visita a
Beijing blinquen afirmó que china se
comprometía a no enviar armamento a
Rusia algo de lo que Washington ha
acusado a los chinos anteriormente Y que
Beijing siempre ha negado Jorge Usted
cree que la visita de blinken puede
ayudar para que china no apoye
militarmente a Rusia
a ver yo creo que la visita del
secretario de estado brinque nos ha dado
éxito importante eran cinco años desde
que un secretario de estado de Estados
Unidos no visitaba china fue recibido no
solo por su contraparte por el canciller
chino a chingan por el ex canciller
wangie hoy encargado máximo de política
exterior en el partido comunista chino y
por el propio presidente de Chile que no
era algo estado originalmente en el
programa de manera que china obviamente
ha hecho un esfuerzo por acomodar al
secretario blinquen dando señales que
quiere calmar las aguas que quiere
estabilizar la relación ahora en
relación al punto específico de entregar
armas a
Rusia yo creo que hasta ahora china el
primero No lo ha hecho segundo ha dicho
que no lo ha hecho y tercero tiene muy
claro que esa es una línea roja que
Estados Unidos ha dicho que no debe
cruzar china Depende como bien sabemos
fuertemente tanto del mercado de Estados
Unidos con el mercado europeo Por ende
yo veo poco probable que está dispuesto
a cruzar esa línea roja que tienen
tendría fuertes consecuencias y así como
para occidente la línea roja es que
china envíe armamento a Rusia para los
chinos la línea roja es que Estados
Unidos intervenga en el asunto de Taiwán
pero quiero volver al tema que
discutíamos al principio del debate y es
las palabras de biden luego del viaje de
blinken usted porque cree que el
presidente estadounidense se pronunció
así
yo creo que no hay que buscar una
racionalidad extremadamente calculada ni
ni ni una estrategia
las palabras tienen consecuencias y los
políticos no siempre
tienen una estrategia detrás de las
palabras que emiten yo diría lo
siguiente obviamente las palabras del
presidente no ayudan al esfuerzo
diplomático que ha hecho
el Estados Unidos por la visita del
secretario de estado
lo que ha hecho lo que han hecho esas
palabras es a poner a Estados Unidos
nuevamente en una situación que va a
tener que de alguna manera
compensar esto que ha ocurrido y
ponerme incentivo para que china siga
adelante con este descongelamiento de
las relaciones no olvidemos que es lo
que está en juego acá es nada menos que
una eventual visita del presidente chi
[Música]
a Estados Unidos a la Cumbre de apec en
San Francisco
obviamente eso es algo que está en juego
para Estados Unidos importante que yo
ocurra y ahí va va a hacer un esfuerzo
para que eso efectivamente pase Y usted
nos da paso precisamente hacia la idea
para concluir este debate y es luego de
este pronunciamiento que viene y quiero
comenzar por usted Lorenzo sobre cuáles
son sus conclusiones sobre todo teniendo
en cuenta que las relaciones entre
Estados Unidos y China tuvieron un punto
de quiebre importante en noviembre de
2022 cuando por primera vez como
presidente Joe biden se reúne con el
marco del g20 en Indonesia y acuerdan un
marco común y comenzar a trabajar
conjuntamente luego de esto pasa lo de
los Globos lo de los posibles encuentros
o acercamientos en el mar de China
meridional lo de la supuesta base de
china en Cuba etcétera y todas las
tensiones que ha habido después ahora la
visita de blinken como bien lo decía
Jorge puede ayudar quizás a descongelar
estas relaciones y ayudar a que sí viaje
finalmente a Washington Usted cree que
las palabras de biden y la visita de
blinquen puedan afectar A favor o en
contra de un descongelamiento de las
relaciones
yo sinceramente soy un poquito pesimista
sobre la relación entre Estados Unidos y
China Estoy seguro que Estados Unidos no
va a dejar no va a reconocer a China
como una potencia igual a la de Estados
Unidos y de otro lado también Está
seguro que los chinos No van a aceptar
una posición de subordinación dentro del
sistema internacional por lo tanto yo
creo que en los próximos meses
seguramente las tensiones van a escalar
seguramente va van a haber comentarios
muy Duros de ambas partes los chinos de
manera tal vez más medida y más calcular
y más planificada tal vez Estados Unidos
va a seguir con esa esquizofrenia que
está teniendo en este momento pero mi
opinión la situación es preocupante y no
para nosotros que somos de países que no
están directamente involucrados esa debe
ser una fuente de preocupación porque
claramente si Estados Unidos y China
escalan las tensiones todo el planeta va
a verse perjudicado en esa esquizofrenia
de la que usted habla los tres coinciden
en un punto y es que las palabras de
biden son desafortunadas Posiblemente no
planeadas y que son una metida de patas
en la relación con china Raquel teniendo
esto en cuenta Cuál es su visión de que
pueda pasar con la diplomacia entre los
dos países
creo que el trabajo fuerte va a estar
efectivamente en estos lazos
diplomáticos es decir en el trabajo que
se puede hacer desde la secretaría de
estado directamente con el Ministerio de
relaciones exteriores chino creo que es
ahí donde se va a tratar de mantener y
subsanar todo este tipo de desencuentros
Sin embargo coincido en esta parte no
tan este optimista en la cual nada
asegura que no pueda suscitarse algún
otro tipo de de Dinámico situación que
vuelva a poner en tensión a a la
relación rescato un poco lo que decía el
embajador respecto a que sí es muy
importante la asistencia del presidente
chillín pin hacia lo que es la reunión
de apk a finales de año pero creo que un
punto previo como una especie de
termómetro para ver cómo va a estar esta
dinámica es la próxima reunión en
septiembre del G veinte donde Pues
también es otro escenario sumamente
estratégico tanto para este Estados
Unidos como para este china respecto a
esto que mencionaba de lindo Pacífico y
cómo se pueda ir generando una agenda
para todo lo que es la región
indopacífica y sobre todo cómo se
insertan tanto china como Estados Unidos
en esta dinámica internacional y ya
veremos si los mandatarios se acercan en
India Como lo hicieron en Bali pero por
ahora ustedes dos coinciden en el punto
pesimista como lo llama lorenza o en el
no optimista como lo llama Raquel frente
al futuro de la diplomacia de estos dos
países Jorge Cuál es su opinión
yo creo que
más que manifestarme como optimista o
pesimista yo buscaría indicios de los
resultados de Esta visita del secretario
por ejemplo hay en carpeta varias
visitas de secretario otro secretarios
de estado de los Estados Unidos de la
secretaría secretaria del tesoro señor
representante especial para
temas de calentamiento global y el
cambio climático
la secretaría de comercio Gina raymondo
también alguna invitación que le realizó
el secretario blinquen a su contraparte
el canciller chinguán a quien yo conocí
mucho mis años Medellín era director de
protocolo en esa época de manera que yo
creo que si esas visitas se realizan
obviamente yo creo que tenemos un
escenario más positivo si esas visitas
por algún motivo no tienen lugar
obviamente es una señal de que no se ha
avanzado todo lo que se podría y esas
visitas deberían tener lugar de acá a
septiembre o sea antes de la realización
de la Cumbre del g20 en Nueva Delhi y la
Cumbre de apec en San Francisco de esta
manera entonces Ni las palabras de biden
ni la visita de blinquen terminan de
determinar Cómo será la relación entre
Estados Unidos y China y tenemos por
delante estos dos eventos de los que
ustedes ya hablaron Gracias por estar
con nosotros Raquel y Samara Lorenzo
mayoreli y Jorge Jaime la producción de
este debate estuvo a cargo de Andrés
doncel y la de los invitados con Tania
Herrera Los invito a que sigan
conectados con la señal de France 24
[Música]